knee arthroscopy is used in the
diagnosis and treatment of a number of
knee disorders and injuries one common
use is in the treatment of meniscal
tears under normal conditions the
menisci C shaped pieces of cartilage
resting between the femur and the tibia
provide cushioning and stability for
your knee joint injuries or arthritis
can cause the menisci to become torn
resulting in knee pain swelling and
diminished range of motion knee
arthroscopy is often performed to remove
the damaged portion of the meniscus when
you arrive at the hospital for your
procedure an intravenous line will be
started and you may be given a sedative
to help you relax the procedure can be
performed under spinal anesthesia which
keeps you numb from the waist down
local anesthesia which keeps your knee
area numb or less commonly general
anesthesia which renders you unconscious
for the duration of the procedure an
arthroscopic min escape t'me usually
takes between 45 and 90 minutes your
surgeon will gain access to your knee
joint by using sharp instruments called
trocars to make two or three small
openings or ports he or she will inject
a sterile solution into the joint to
push the surfaces apart allowing the
structures inside the joint to be viewed
more easily next your surgeon will
insert the arthroscope and other
instruments through the various ports
images from the Arthur scopes camera are
magnified and projected onto a video
monitor your surgeon will carefully
examine the inside of your knee joint
locate the damage remove any loose or
severely injured parts and use a shaving
instrument to smooth any jagged edges
while it may be possible to repair the
meniscus with small stitches in most
cases the damaged portion must be
removed at the end of the procedure your
surgeon will again carefully examine the
entire knee for any areas of bleeding or
other damage remove the arthroscope and
other instruments and close each of the
keyhole incisions with a few sutures
after your surgery you will be taken to
the recovery area for monitoring where
you will be given pain medication as
needed most patients leave the
outpatient surgery unit within a few
hours